space this put face in front of anything
and that's a better version of that I'm
scared of space if I went to space
I'd be the coolest thing ever a new
taste in space there's anything working
space cookies and cream ice cream
certified space technology you know yes
this is like a prop Ice Cream Sandwich
wow that is so terrifying
oh oh that was like biting into a grip
actually this is delicious
it just says I got a really dry oreo it
is not an Ice Cream Sandwich because
that's a lie
here's something to remind you of home
but it's gonna taste completely
different it's like a brick feels like
ramen this look like food oh it does
smell like chocolate chip ice cream I
think it smells like plastic pretending
to be ice cream it's like dry
marshmallows not the worst the flavor is
so good huh but the texture is so bad
for me I almost feel like I want to put
that on top of the ice cream yeah I was
in space I would eat this and believe
it's ice cream
it's like drugs this is like
freeze-dried dippin dots I'm thinking
this is amazing Neapolitan ice cream
that's your favorite two flavors of ice
cream and then strawberry these little
pellets
they're so cute little ice cream poops
oh oh no oh no oh God Frieden are
different awesome love it
it tastes like tongue it's like dead
Neapolitan ice cream was like expired
cool concept not into that place favor
yeah but if you ate just a diet of
astronaut food you would feel pretty
pristine shape I did like my favorite
ice cream say I like thanks cream
sandwich I would have that like here on
a daily basis but also who are we
kidding like we we defunded NAPLAN we
don't send anyone to space anymore so
the dream is dead
it's just so sad what's happening over
there